coming up on Star Talk we've got a
cosmic queries Edition all about
exoplanets I've got with me one of the
world's experts on that subject anelie
trapathy welcome to Star Talk we're
going to find out where she came from
where she's been and where she's going
in this world of not only exop planets
but also as a citizen scientist serving
two presidents coming up on Star
[Music]
clock this is Star Talk Neil theg grass
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
today is another Cosmic queries ever
popular format that that is on the
subject of exoplanets Chuck yeah my
co-host how you feeling Chuck I'm
feeling great man feeling good about the
exoplanet exoplanets are always um a fod
for great thought cuz now we know that
there are millions and millions of
them they're everywhere I don't know if
the catalog has quite hit that yet we
went from four they're like maybe
there's
four so I don't little bit about
exoplanets but if we're going to really
go in with the cosmic quaries we're
bring in the big guns okay so we combed
the
landscape and we found anelie trapathy
anelie welcome to Star talk thank you so
much so excited to be here excellent
excellent you uh you in your
professional life not only uh did
original work on exop planets you are
also found yourself either on purpose or
otherwise at the intersection between
science and Society absolutely so I want
to get to that in just a minute right
now you're a research associate at
NASA's JPL which Chuck stands for what
um I believe Judy pson uh lingerie
that's right Judy polson's lingerie it's
all the r no that's usually classified
why'd you let that one out classified
information yeah now awesome jet
propulsion Labs the jet propulsion labs
in Pasadena California yes and there
it's not only a branch of NASA they
collaborate and are basically on the
campus of Caltech right I am a Caltech
employee right right so no who signs
your checks is it Caltech Caltech wow
okay there it is but you still have NASA
overlords I'm pretty sure you do uh you
know who we had on Star Talk just when
she just started was the director of of
JPL Lori Le she and I serve on a a
commission to study the future of NASA w
we both appointed by President George W
bush nice and said she went on to great
things and I and you um you got stuck
with me I'm so sorry I'm so sorry what a
shame but you could dig the Lori Leon
episode out of our archives that's that
was fun right uh I wanted to get to her
before NASA got to her because you know
NASA they get they want to overcontrol
the the interviews but she and I go way
back right so there was an interval
where let's just rock and roll this
exactly just say what you think think
what you feel yeah well you're not going
to be able to do that with anelie
because NASA is still controlling her
sorry I got the NASA handcuffs on okay
no no we'll figure something out here so
um at at JPL what are your primary
concerns uh I like thinking about what
can we see from space right so what can
you see when you look up at exoplanets
and other worlds and also looking down
here on Earth and how can improve life
here on it you know people when they
think of space exploration they don't
always think that from space you can see
Earth as a planet exactly and monitor
what's going on and how we doing you
know so this this seems to be a really
important feature of what NASA can
deliver the public yeah it's something
folks always get wrong you ask them
what's our most studied Planet at Nasa
and they go Mars and you go wrong and
you think it's Earth and nobody realizes
that exactly so you still have Roots
back where you got your PhD I do yeah
I'm a research associate at the Harvard
Smithsonian Center for astrophysics okay
all right so tell tell me before we get
back into exop planets because that's
where we got all the questions are based
on those yes they are uh just uh your
the science and Society part of your
life how did that begin so being a
valley girl you know we had an
earthquake in the 90s and I had to move
out of my house for a year and the
people who come on TV for those of you
who've had the pleasure of earthquakes
it's a seismologist who comes and tells
you what's going to happen and I thought
scientist can come and tell you what's
going to happen next and sort of save
things I want to do that and then I
learned that seismology and geophysics
and physics are important but they don't
save the world in the same way and so
thinking about how you can find
connections between science and servant
you know why they don't save the world
because they only bring the geology on
after the earthquake after the
earthquake not just before the
earthquake after the earthquake true
okay they saving nobody it's a dog shame
because like when do we really need them
we just got some readings in that's when
we need them whereas with the
astronomers we're like that Eclipse get
ready it's coming in six months okay
total predictive Powers yeah all right
so now what so okay so you the urge
doesn't make the reality so what
happened I mean I was lucky enough I
went and served in two administrations
President Obama brought me in as a White
House fellow she was lucky that was just
luck I was going to say that was just
luck yeah I mean I don't like to talk
about the bribes I served in two
administrations that's funny I used to
serve at
Wendy I was Wendy's
manager and I served for for two for two
tours of Duty two tours of Duty wait so
who thank you for your
service who so who was your first
president uh well I mean I was born a
while ago when lady doesn't reveal her
age but of the two administrations we're
going to triangulate on that if you give
us enough information uh President Obama
President Obama okay and so what in what
capacity were you serving the white
house so I came in serving uh the US
Department of Agriculture thinking about
climate change you know it doesn't
matter why your soil is dry you got to
get things to grow that's right is there
a relationship between the Department of
Agriculture and the Environmental
Protection Agency I mean so I was
working on food waste right which is
something that both care about right
because I mean you know your Apple that
you don't eat turns into methane
greenhouse gas right without a doubt so
all right so but you didn't just so how
does the Obama
Administration connect you to
agriculture what is that pathway uh you
know where else would you put an
astrophysicist in government wa what was
your what you what was your title I was
a White House fellow oh you didn't say
that okay a White House fellow and so
you have these science fellows at the
white house so the White House fellows
are actually I was the only scientist I
didn't know that yeah so it's a group
about there's 16 in my class right so
one of them is now a congresswoman we've
got all kinds of folks lot from the
military and business and law the idea
is you go and you serve a cabinet
secretary as a senior advisor because
the cabinet reports to the president so
this is still a White House thing
exactly so the secretary of agriculture
then became exact who reports to the
president and you were working with them
I'm I'm intrigued by the fact that you
get a PhD studying exoplanets so you're
thinking about planets looking at them
from afar right and then Earth and
agriculture becomes Earth that you're
thinking about from afar so what kind of
NASA or astronomical insights can you
offer the Department of Agriculture well
I mean I want it to be more down toe
let's be honest right and the idea is
just that you know you can see so much
more from satellites than you can with a
guy walking around with a
mule hey they offered to send me to
estimator school where they said you're
going to walk a certain number of Paces
in a corn field pick the second ear of
corn you see and count the diameter and
across and that's how we estimate the
crop yields in America we still to this
day don't use satellite technology for
the government predictions on crop what
this Green Acres that I was CRA that's
crazy you got Arnold the pig predicting
the weather like what hey man uh so how
big is your corn like like that's crazy
it's quantitative you count you know but
I mean it's one of those things that
it's really useful for all the companies
that come in because then it's
calibrated ground truth right okay I me
I mean a way that makes sense so now but
but isn't it much better to look at
because you can see from space you can
actually see soil conditions you can see
the the crop yields themselves there are
I mean Dr how dry you can see you know
is there's so much more information you
can get from looking down from above so
is what's going on with that I mean and
your question right there is tons of
NASA data that looks at the soil
moisture it looks at sort of the
different vegetation and that's all
publicly available both to the Agri
culture department and anybody else and
to the person pacing cornfields right
correct it's available to them right but
maybe they need a job exactly the farmer
needs a job I don't know so no so I'm
intrigued by this so okay so that was a
tour of Duty it went across the
administrations that's right and but
then you ended up you told me offline
you ended up at the office of Science
and Technology policy which is the
executive branch that oversees the
budget for science in the United States
wow for science yeah for science right
and so what were we doing there what are
we doing with that
$326 wait what are you talking about you
said the budget for science oh this
it's a little bigger than that I was
going to say that's what it there's a
lot of science that they apply to the
military and so then then you talking
big bucks okay I'm just saying there you
go like Department of energy comes under
that department that's some nuclear
stuff right there there some nuclear
totally nuclear some nuclear stuff going
down right on okay so go no I mean you
know writing about hey what are we
investing in what are the people and the
programs and I figured that we added the
word American in front of everything we
want to do so we wanted American Health
right not just Health American Health
that was smart thank you I mean that is
brilliant because when you look at con
americ you should have made it that
instead of American you got to spell it
right apostrophe m u r i mer mer they
didn't teach me that one in my spelling
classes you know okay so that was clever
and so now more people of course the all
can take ownership of it right that's
right yeah no I mean it was I will say
coming in to a new admin ation it's kind
of crazy your hard drives get wiped
everything is gone you're starting fresh
a little bit and uh lots of opportunity
to learn so whether you wanted me to
have that opportunity or not but I think
you know we did some good stuff but
would you have normally been discarded
between administrations how did oh how
did you stay on so White House fellows
have a one-year appointment that's fixed
and so started August of 2016 went to
August of 2017 oh you start at the end
of the Obama Administration oh so you
crossover I got you you were a part of
the transition I was okay very cool
so at the time you told me again Offline
that you knew I was on a pentagon board
at the time how did you know about that
because I I go into five-sided buildings
I can handle that not just four-sided
ones okay right on how many five-sided
buildings do you know I don't know cuz I
work at the
hexagon okay I mean top that's that's
why do you think the telescopes have
these hexagonal mirrors right yeah yeah
the mirror segments of J J heag that's
right so that's a that's top secret
nobody about except for you there you go
that's right you know where we came up
with that idea at the
hexagon not not
the okay what's your most recent
published paper was it about about
climate change yeah we just wrote a
paper together about sea level rise and
how you can use satellite data to
actually do better job of preparing
coastal cities for excellent R yeah only
where like most everybody lives every
major city
a body of
water what can satellites do for you
right okay but again it sounds like the
the the seismologist it's like here's
what you do when the water knocks at
your door rather can is there
preventative no this is all about how
cities uh can look at you know glaciers
in Antarctica and you know Greenland
melting now to prepare for what's
happening in the future right rather
than waiting for the level to actually
rise
early warning oh so you can make
predictions anticipate got it that's
amazing got it and plus I'm not thinking
about Antarctica or Greenland exctly
when I don't live near them but their
water doesn't carry passports right that
water molecule go wherever wherever it
goes yes exactly so let's get back to
exoplanets absolutely so so uh your work
for your PhD was what thinking about how
planets form and how they evolve over
time oh formation of exoplanets good
nice so somebody had to make them right
they're not just born whole no exactly
okay yeah so Chuck you got a question
for it we have them right here let do
you want to jump right into this let's
do it all right I love this first one
this is manell Hicks and manell says hi
Dr Tyson hi Anjali planets are
evaporating that's it that's all that it
says I mean Monell's got it down planets
are evaporating right I mean we got the
Earth we got exoplanets right because
you've got all this gas that we call the
atmosphere that's trying to stick to the
planet by gravity but sometimes you got
the heat from that star that's enough
that it just pulls it off well we're
losing what helium and what's the other
thing hydrogen hydrogen and helium on a
daily basis hourly minute seconds yeah
wow okay but not so fast that I should
worry about it and make a thing on but
but if uh there's stars that get
brighter more luminous and they're
gashri right planets so they how about
those big Jupiters that are orbiting
close to their host are they evaporating
yeah these planets right that we call
Hot Jupiters because they're so close in
right and especially since they've
always got one side often facing the
star the same sides they locked exactly
the Moon is tily locked to us if you get
close to a a massive source of gravity
it's going to lock you and only look at
one side just as we did to the Moon the
Moon is trying to do that to us did you
know just just yeah just lead us down
the wrong path It's Just A New Path new
like a new yeah don't value judge the
path it's just it's just the orbital
mechanics of it come on then we're going
over here come on why you
I'm just saying go so the Moon is trying
to slow us down so we only show the same
face yeah that's why we throw a leap
seconds every now and then to make up
for that but any so so wait a minute
with the
evaporation just because I'm concerned
about Earth to be honest uh what's going
to happen first well our atmosphere
which I understand from Neil is like
thinner than the skin of an apple okay
is thinner than the skin of Apple will
that evaporate before the Sun expands
and kills us all or what's going to
happen first all right Chuck don't worry
about it don't worry about it a lot of
things that I'll scare you with this
isn't want of them right so the idea is
that you will have this atmospheric
Escape is what they call it because your
atmosphere is literally escaping the
planet happening more and more in the
future as the sun gets brighter but it's
not all going to go away before then so
you're you're safe okay so you're good
but again if falling around the surface
of the Earth trying to breathe right
stay low like like you're in a
fire stop dropping Roll Just so you can
breathe well I think you're going to
want to you know go up towards the poles
or something like that the quator is not
going to look so hot or maybe it is
going to look so hot yeah that's the
problem okay well you already got this
planned out you can move to joining
Santa
Claus all right what else you got CH all
right here this is TJ's show who says hi
TJ here from Winnipeg Canada e um does
not have that in there no they don't
okay they do not okay okay it says uh
thanks for taking my question hello Dr
Tyson Dr tathy and Lord nice longtime
listener new patreon here um my question
is about intelligent life if there are
roughly 10 million unique organisms on
Earth 99% of all species that have ever
existed are extinct and we are only the
the only intelligent species out of all
that questionable let me say
questionable big assumption big
assumption uh then doesn't that mean
that the likelihood there being
intelligent life on a newly discovered
habitable world is about one in a
billion oh I like that okay so there you
fast fast back of the envelope math
envelope math there so he says yeah so
in know and then he goes on our galaxy
might be teaming with life but
intelligent life could be
extremely rare so let me let me recast
that in another way so if you have a
dark if you have only so his Earth
there's this one branch of vertebrates
coming out of fish that became great
apes right okay I've known some eights
but not all of them were great well no
some of them were just not so great so
and one Thin branch of that are the
humans anything could have stop that
right the a the asteroid not taking out
the dinosaurs would have disrupted the
mammals from ever even quote ascending
to where just just sheer luck okay bad
luck dinosaur good so if this is just
one branch out of the tens of millions
of life forms if you have tens of
millions of earths close your eyes and
throw a dart
really most of them will just have life
like we got here just life but it will
not be uh developed react to that I'm
just saying I'm not smart enough to know
what else is out there in the universe
and certainly not the numbers of that so
I think you know if we're being honest
do we know if there's life out there I
don't know do I hope there's life out
there heck yeah do I hope it's
intelligent heck yeah but the numbers
one in a billion let's take the
intelligence out okay now the fact is
let let's factor that
out what is the likelihood of just life
I don't care if it's single cell life I
don't care if it's just you know like uh
you know some type of uh bacteria or
amibas whatever what's the likelihood of
that happening seeing as how you know
the same building blocks that we have
here are everywhere yeah plus it happen
pretty quickly on Earth yeah I mean
we're only 4.5 billion years old and we
got to the Life part pretty damn quickly
I mean this planet everywhere right like
every Star has planets and so if you
think about we've got so many planets so
many balls of rock are probably amongst
those planets chances are good you had
the conditions for life right you know
water some energy those things seem like
they're out there so I think the chances
are good but again one in a billion I
don't know if it's that slim yeah plus
we're not even limit it to rocky planets
anymore because there's some there's
some good moons there are some great Mo
that habitable worlds right not just
habitable planet worlds not just planets
World forget Planet non Planet world
okay and then yeah yeah yeah I mean like
even even like a ice well what would be
like an ice world like uncel or you got
that water underneath right yeah but
that could happen right like okay toly
all right here we go this is Dylan and
Dylan says greetings everyone from
Flagstaff Arizona I'm taking
undergraduate astrophysics courses and
learning about spectro uh
spectroscopy thank you spectroscopy
spectroscopy I can't always gets me and
other amazing methods of how to find and
characterize planets what ha what has
been the best method so far to find
planets and what possible new methods
are being thought up so let me let me
Focus that down and have you tell us
we're now using spectroscopy to study
the atmosphere of these PL so what's
coming out of that I mean it's amazing
that when you get just the right
configuration that you've got the star
on the planet passes in front of it and
you're looking at that some of the light
goes through that atmosphere of that
planet from the start and gets to us and
so we can actually see some of those
chemicals in that atmosphere so we so
the chemicals are are are disrupting
really the clean path of light the star
and that disruption shows up in the
Spectrum right they were like putting
their fingers on there getting those
finger fings yeah so what are you
looking for it so we've seen carbon
dioxide with the James web Space
Telescope which is pretty cool right the
first time we've seen that on another
exoplanet all right uh right all kinds
of other compounds right we get water
okay sure water molecule yeah right you
got some good things in there and all
kinds of configurations of oxygen and
carbon and hydrogen that you're think
about methane methane is pretty great
right you get methane there too have you
seen it yet there is methane about on
the planets yeah okay that would be
evidence of farts it can be it can be
all right keep going that is so cool
this is uh Cesar by the way just to just
to bring closure to that to say that the
boring obvious fact so many of these
planets were discovered exactly were
discovered with just by their Spectra
right and by transit right that you
looked at the light and you saw it
blinking and that's just because
something kep going around at that light
of the star the transit is the planet
going in front of the Stars light
rocking the star's light it's just like
when we'd have eclipses where you block
out the whole face of the star but here
it's just a fraction of it right so we
talk about in fact solar eclipses are
really transits that yes we talk about
the transits of Mercury and Venus
little mercury Transit Venus trans it's
a moon Transit that's right and and an
eclipse technically
astronomically is just object moving
into the shadow of another object okay
so a total solar eclipse really we
shouldn't use the term Eclipse but we do
all right yeah nice uh this is Cesar
erno who says hello Dr Tyson Dr trapathy
is the James web Space Telescope used to
look for exoplanets heck yeah okay so
why don't we just zoom in on some
exoplanets and she said heck yes heck
yeah heck we heard that no let me hear
it real you're you're in New York City
you're in Manhattan say that right
yeah I'm sorry I don't think I can beat
that I chuck chuck wins
that that was just too New York I
couldn't that that's a long bleep on
that one okay no I think if I had the
teacher instead of I love New York it
would be I love gwst right for the ex
planets oh yeah yeah James web space so
the so I thought it would only be
looking closer at exop plets we've
already discussed is it is there a
discovery mode there are discoveries too
yeah how does it do that I mean it
actually captures pictures where you see
that there's uh planets in the
frame wow without knowing that in
advance yeah yeah oh so he said why
don't we just zoom in and get some high
quality images and that's exactly what
you just it's doing wait wait so wait
wait so you see the host star and you
see the planet you get you get a hint of
the planet being there a hint of the
plan get a little little dip of tea
right dip of planets gotcha but uh you
know the question of can we zoom in on
planets there you know James Webb is
looking at different patches of sky and
if there are planets in there that's
great but it can't look at just any part
of the sky and say zooming in deeper and
deeper because planets don't give off a
lot of light they're just reflecting
their Starlight which is so faint that
you don't see it most of the time yeah
gotcha all right this is Gavin Bamber
who says hello from North Vancouver
where plant life flourishes and he's not
lying that's that's it's so green up
there oh you can go green led up there
it's crazy it's crazy he says once we
find plan our animal life on other
planets uh oh will we be able to eat it
or can we tell if we're able to eat it
or for Chuck will we be able to smoke it
well that's a question for you CH wait
did he say that yes he did no he didn't
yeah I swear to God he said we will we
be able to smoke it but okay so let me
ask that ask this so do can we only I
don't know how much biology you know um
but can we process
organic matter that has a different DNA
from us like our DNA is right-handed
like it spirals this way y uh like
clockwise looking up double he yeah but
in principle you can have DNA doing the
other direction right the chemistry
shouldn't matter right all right except
we don't and all those people's skin is
on the inside of their
body that's how all their organs are on
the outside they are so messy looking so
what what what is the scholarship on
just the digestibility of life forms
that are not native to Earth our
researcher doesn't eat and tell Neil a
researcher doesn't eat and
tell I don't know why that got
me but I mean I would say you know would
you want to though right because I mean
there's so many things that you're like
oh that cheese doesn't look quite right
I don't know if I want to eat that now
you're going I just found this out there
foraged for some while yeah yeah yeah
funny there's a whole lot of stuff on
Earth you know not to eat now you that
desperate to eat aliens right I'm just
saying would you want
to so this is Daniel L Thompson who says
howy Dr Tyson Dr trafi and Sir nice
that's Lord nice uh he says Lord is
above sir Lord exactly Lord is why would
you demote me uh he goes uh I'm Daniel
from uh High School in the uh AF Jr RC
um a junior air Air Force Reserve
officer training Corps good for you
buddy nice um um he says has there been
a minimum and maximum size or density to
Define what would be survivable for
humans I like that to live I like that
uh yeah and PS Chuck you're welcome for
the easy name well thank you Daniel and
I but you can't take credit I'm gon
thank your parents for
that but anyway is there I mean I I
suppose planet sizes and other pressure
atmospheric pressure or gas planets
whatever all those things would have a
there was a movie The Space Between Us
where someone grew up on
Mars an astronaut got pregnant on the
night before launch yeah and it takes
nine months to get to Mars and NASA had
to hide that information so she gave
birth on Mars and no one knew about it
and then the kid came back to Earth and
it was like that's pretty cool he had a
hard time breathing and you know all
those things he was used to on Mars his
muscles could couldn't but he was still
alive it didn't kill him so do you have
any thoughts on survivability of low or
high gravity I mean I'm a big fan of
earth right so like look for planets
like Earth because you know I like being
able to jump up and down rather than
Jupiter I don't jump up where you going
next right right and uh you know having
that nice solid surface so you know
something sort of the size of Earth is
nice and cozy we seem to do okay to your
point is if it's much more massive than
Earth it's not a rocky planet it's
gaseous G because it kept all of its gas
okay so that's that's out the upper end
of that's out upper end's out I don't
know how low we can go right because we'
got moons that are possibly good places
to live right our moon is 1 six gravity
right right so that's not going to kill
you it's not going to kill you you're
going to get some help you don't want to
get used to it and then come back to
yeah I mean three generations later you
know you have the bone density of a
marshmallow but you got the space suit
right that you know it's a souvenir
right all I got was a lousy space suit
right when I
came you're not gonna be bond for my
souvenir shop anytime soon are you all
right understand it's okay so I mean I
think you know down on the lower end
it's hard to say how low you can go it
is interesting though that when we look
out at exoplanets find some where there
are these little planets that actually
end up just getting evaporated away so
instead of their atmospheres being all
that evaporates you got just like
crumbly Planet going off into space
right so you got the wrong conditions
there so it's not just the size of the
planet it's how close it is to the star
and everything else it's feeling so it
probably feels tidal forces that'll
disrupt structurally too okay but when
when they say super Earths we've heard
this that's right Planets super how how
big is super bigger than Earth right
smaller than Neptune right right so you
think like it's in between so you might
be twice your gravity something like
that right we talk about it in terms of
the radius of it so how's the size of it
because the super earth right it could
have a surface it could be a little bit
more puffy okay but so how big a radius
compared to if it's a super depends on
your definition right it's a few times a
few times yeah okay a few times that's
pretty big that's pretty big right
normally when people think of oh twice
the size but if you can range 10 and 100
times bigger a factor two is just
friendly you know exactly I mean we have
a poster that we made of people
skydiving on a super Earth because they
thought oh that'd be fun right
yeah you be falling faster I personally
don't think it be fun but our art team
thinks it's great and I I think that's
great but you know there was also the
question in there of the density right
and I definitely want to be on that ball
of rock rather than that ball of gas
like Jupiter because I like having a
surface want to land somewhere and and
yeah and so but what if like when they
when when we retrieved uh you know part
of the asteroid right we were able to do
so because we put the uh the drill down
in a place where we knew it was crumbly
Rock so what if we know that it's a
super Earth but it's kind of made of
that kind of that composition of crumbly
Rock I mean I would love to get to that
point right right now I'm just like it
it weighs this much it seems this big
divide some numbers I don't think that's
a real thing really yeah because if it's
big enough and has a strong enough
gravity right it'll right it will
condense the problem with the asteroids
they don't have much gravity so so
they're like Loosely they're loose plus
it didn't drill it was a touch and go it
was right it was bang and then it sucked
up grabbed whatever whatever came up
inside of it yes right and they were
ready for just a couple ounces they got
the half a pound right half a pound so
they were good but no that you're you're
right the gravity makes a a that that
makes sense you got to be a plan got to
be plan live have you said you try
that you Tred that I was just like you
know what Neil you
right all right we got time for like one
and a half questions one more all right
okay let's go with Andrew nisker and
Andrew says hello from flesherton
Ontario can you please explain the
different types of biomarker gases how
will the next generation of telescopes
enhance our ability to study exoplanets
guess that's two separate questions but
hey I'm always looking up so I have to
ask lots of questions picking up on the
earlier question you mentioned uh water
molecule uh methane and carbon dioxide
but is there like the greatest hits of
what would reveal life on the on the on
the surface I mean there's so many
different ways that we can search for
exoplanets with life right those
signatures right we call them bio
signatures or techno signatures we even
want to go a little further a field and
so the fact that you know you could look
for pollution on a planet right that be
techno signature that well depending on
how you count it yeah right but I mean
like you look for chlorocarbons right
from your you know hairspray on your
alien world okay you know that would be
a slam dunk for life even though it's
not one of the things we've historically
always studied right these sorts of
things and so you know signatures like
methane wait wa so the core FOC carbons
they're
idiots but they're idiots we can see
right intelligent like there ex they're
getting rid of their ozone layer which
is probably what they're saying about us
when they actually see the biomarkers
from this planet or the techn markers
from this planet they're like I mean
it's like if you were really smart would
you want people to see you and find you
so anymore what's it phosphate was one
of them uh so phosphine is something
people have talked about possibly no no
it's all good it's all good uh being
detected possibly in Venus and whether
that's a sign of life or something else
it's probably something else there but I
think there are lots of detections of
all of these more complicated molecules
right where you start putting things
together that would be there only if you
have life on the surface that could be
caused by life right you know like the
chlorofluorocarbons would only be cus by
life but methane could be common from
something else something else okay
because you get you can get naturally
occurring methe so what about oxygen
oxygen could be there it can be I mean I
don't know how you get oxygen unless
somebody's making it like with plants I
mean like look at the history of the
Earth right for billions of years we've
existed and we didn't have this much
oxygen all that whole time right like go
back in time so you not only need to
look at that planet and just see what it
is but at this particular moment in time
when I saw the original Star Trek do do
you remember the original Star Trek no
one ever wore a space suit no when they
went down on they didn't wear space suit
they never wore masks anything you know
why because they they but they would
establish uh oxygen nitrogen atmosphere
Captain well let's go on down it's a
Class M Planet exactly breathable
atmosphere so I'm thinking oh if you
just look hard enough you find other
oxygen nitrogen planets and then I
realized later that you're only getting
the oxygen from living matter on the
planet it's not just some random mixture
right in the random assortment of Planet
somebody's making the oxygen and Earth
it's our plant life PL life but I mean
we can also you know when you form a
planet you got all kinds of chemistry
going on in there and things going into
the rocks and so what goes on in your
atmosphere some of that just happens
naturally okay okay so you're gonna have
to distinguish those right cases and
that's so getting the list is one thing
and then you fight about whether it's
biological or not exactly at conferences
yeah that's good that was a good
question time for one half a question oh
my god let's see let's go with Captain
James Riley who says hello everyone
Texas here is there a most common
atmospheric composition out there among
rocky planets I like that that's related
to that last question related I love
that question I think in the last
question he asked about the telescopes
and I think the answer is we need more
data right to answer this because we
haven't been able to tell the atmosphere
allow you to cop out and just say we
need more data talk to me me but I mean
I think that's the thing is that so many
of these things because if it's a cloudy
day you can't see what's going on
underneath right you see clouds you see
like water vapor up there right so
there's so many of these systems where
you think like hey I need this new new
telescope okay so of all the planets
where we know anything about their
atmosphere is there an emergent common
list I think it's kind of like the zoo
right there's some common things like
there's all those things with Tails
there's all those things with oxygen
there's all those things with carbon and
methane right it's the sort of thing
that we haven't seen enough to be able
to say this is the most common thing yet
so not yet Zoo you have animal with
Tails an with four
legs things with wings right like it's
just start classifying them you start
blunt right start I think what it means
is we got to chat more again in a few
years and then we can do better come
back come back well very cool by the way
I I understand you have a TED Talk I do
yeah on on atmospheric Escape oh okay
okay well I'm not watching that I'm
scared to death but but you know that
How It Ends you know you're safe know
itend I'll die long before yeah so
you're the first to model The Escape of
gas from from atmospheres uh doing that
in 3D for these planets model oh cool in
the old days computers weren't fast and
we didn't have ai and so you do like ond
modeling and 2D modeling just to
approximate the 3D modeling because you
couldn't calculate it and then when
confus get fast enough and she comes
along I got this 3D Boom all in there
you go and it's CAU because you're
modeling G gas right you're just
watching it flow yeah yeah this the flow
of gas in a computer model that's not e
it's not let it go it's let it flow
right right okay what which's but yeah
but I mean what's funny is like isn't
that like gas is what's that as it gas
moves towards entropy it's just no chaos
right so what do you somewhere in
between right because it was starting on
the planet in the atmosphere and just
blowing off into space okay so that's
what you're doing you're going from
where it's very more stable and then to
its instability there you go okay all
right good Chuck is good till the next
time I'm feeling better he feel a little
better better I mean you got to be
feeling totally
better so Angelie thanks for coming up
on to start off thanks for having me we
continue to follow your career
appreciate that uh you know there's
still a few more presidents you can for
exactly you know don't
slouch you got to get back in the white
house so yes I mean I'm the exlan
Ambassador though right now right so got
to go visit those exlan to event you
have an ambassador title oh yeah no I'm
NASA's exit Planet Ambassador oh sweet
oh my God that's very cool so so do you
speak at the
UN speak I speak for the state
department the galactic un oh yeah there
you go you get to speak that's so when
the aliens come we when they say take me
to our leader I'll say we have an
ambassador we have an ambassador is that
good
enough something like that yeah no we
say we ain't taking you our leader
you're the Ambassador is going be what
you're gonna meet here we believe me yes
it will it will be a scientist or Taylor
Swift the doctor will see you
now all right well good luck in your
continued career and your ambassadorship
and we we want a full update all right
sounds good as more exoplanets show up
and more aliens visit okay you'll be
first on the list all right all right
good this has been Star Talk Neil theg
grass Tyson here your personal
astrophysics Chuck thanks for always a
pleasure all right and as always I bid
you keep fcking
[Music]
up